et là j'ai eu cette photo quand même qui
est surprenante d'une silhouette un peu
en suspension
mais nous avons nous des pouvoirs
inconnus et j'étais en train de prier
quand j'ai eu vraiment tous ces flashs
qui me sont arrivés j'ai même plus que
d'échanger des visions
oui depuis que je suis petit moi je vois
tout ceux qui sont partis de l'autre
côté nous avons bien faire un au-delà
dans lequel il y a des êtres qui vivent
et pour nous ce sont nos défunts
[Musique]
on va passer une expérience de millième
nuitée ce sont les personnes qui sont
devenus invisibles qui vont venir vous
donner des messages voilà
enfin tu dire ce que c'est cette énergie
quoi cette lumière est-ce que c'est un
objet est-ce que c'est autre chose que
ce que c'est un fantôme c'est ça qu'on
appelle un fantôme
ils ont leur origine dans la
personnalité des individus
[Musique]
histoire commence dans le nord de la
France
je lisais par hasard un article sur
l'histoire d'une abbaye censée être la
plus hantée de France on y voit
régulièrement l'apparition de fantômes
et plus particulièrement celui d'une
dame blanche
et c'était le début de mon enquête
[Musique]
Mathilde
fille de toutes les séductions et de
tous les sortilèges
[Musique]
Mathilde
fille de la nuit que les traditions qui
courent autour de Mortemer disent auprès
de condamné à une amor certaine
ceux qui l'ont vu deux fois
Mathilde
surprendre l'ombre dans les ruines par
les nuits de pleine lune
Mathilde
sa mère à la fois
croyance et superstition
[Musique]
je vais envie de connaître cette pays
dont j'avais entendu parler toutes les
ruines étaient éclairée j'ai pris des
photos des ruines et là j'ai eu cette
photo quand même qui est surprenante
d'une silhouette un peu en suspension
est le plus curieux c'est que j'ai rien
vu heureusement parce que
je me serais inquiété quand même mon
équilibre mental
moi personnellement je pense que ça
représente une silhouette peut-être de
femmes un peu de trois quarts il y a pas
d'autres femmes un peu voilée ou
et puis une chouette Bourges je pense
qu'on la voit mieux là
se détacher alors c'est une photo qui
s'est interposée ou c'est vous avez le
souvenir de l'avoir prise ah bah non
j'ai pris moi des ruines pendant combien
d'années et de 84 si on compte la
première
avec l'esprit juste en 99 la dernière
fois où j'y suis allé parce que j'en ai
eu assez voilà 99 de 93 99 tous les ans
à la même époque tous les gens que j'ai
eu cette foutu si loin
et vous poursuit
parce que j'aimerais avoir une
explication quelle qu'elle soit je suis
assez cartésienne j'ai ouverte
des choses inexpliquées mais qu'on
m'explique
les professionnels photographiquement
dit que c'était pas possible d'obtenir
une photo comme ça avec les flashs
actuels en plus que le flash est pas
parti mais que il y avait une luminosité
qui était inexplicable voilà à partir de
ce moment-là j'ai cherché du côté par un
psychologique alors j'ai fait une de ce
qui s'appelle une NDE une mort
temporaire il y a de ça maintenant 29
ans
et que beaucoup de gens qui ont eu cette
morte temporaire aurait des perceptions
enfin des une sensibilité particulière
je refuse plein de choses
c'est tout ce que j'ai obtenu qui me
explication
[Musique]
je vais l'écrire sous la forme Xa sur
factorialisme là par un psychologie
c'est l'étude des voyants c'est l'étude
des guérisseurs c'est l'étude des gens
qui disent j'ai été témoin d'une
apparition j'ai vu un fantôme
les phénomènes
parapsychologiques à mes yeux ne sont
pas inexplicables ils sont seulement
encore inexpliqués
le tonnerre était paranormal pour les
Grecs les anciens Grecs quand ils
entendent le tonnerre disaient mais
c'est une querelle de ménage chez eux
c'est revenir à dire pour eux c'est
paranormal nous le constatons mais nous
ne le comprenons pas et puis un jour on
a compris le tonnerre on a mis un peu de
temps et les Grecs n'étaient plus là
pour profiter de l'explication mais
l'explication a été trouvée par la
pensée rationnelle c'est ça le principe
parce que bien entendu ce phénomène sont
naturels ils ont leur origine dans la
personnalité des individus mais nous
avons nous des pouvoirs inconnus
et l'étude de ces pouvoirs inconnus
vraiment oui c'est un défi énorme qui
est jeté à la rationalité
certains scientifiques émettent
l'hypothèse que le cerveau humain est
bien plus complexe que l'Univers
lui-même
la part psychologie est probablement une
piste sérieuse
et depuis qu'on le sollicite le
laboratoire a réussi à résoudre 95% des
phénomènes mais 5% restent tout de même
une énigme totale
[Musique]
parmi tous les cas de photos
paranormales celui de Muriel me paraît
être le plus frappant
je sais qu'une association a fait des
tests sur le terrain avec elle elle a
peut-être une nouvelle piste
[Musique]
alors je dirais qu'au départ il y a un
intérêt un intérêt pour ce qui paraît
actuellement encore inexpliqué et ça ça
me tient depuis mon plus jeune âge donc
étant de ayant eu cette ce problème du
deuil finalement ça m'a relancé un petit
peu sur une recherche d'ailleurs qui
était très motivée puisque c'était le
départ de mon premier épouse et là j'ai
essayé de voir s'il y avait quelque
chose qui se passait après donc là c'est
le domaine de la TCI et puis en même
temps j'ai repris un petit peu mes
passions du début c'est-à-dire essayer
sur le terrain comme vous dites de voir
s'il y avait moyen d'apporter des
preuves par rapport à certains
phénomènes que l'on dit paranormaux ou
de témoigner actuellement
ma conclusion je n'irai pas jusqu'à dire
à 100% que c'est une photo paranormale
mais il y a beaucoup d'éléments quand
même qui suggèrent une photo paranormale
alors il y a premièrement cette forme
déjà il y a deuxièmement cette présence
apparemment de quelque chose qui
ressemble à un animal donc une chouette
et je dirais qu'un autre élément qui me
semble relativement fondamental que l'on
a constaté c'est que en faisant
l'expérience avec Muriel sur place
je suis allé moi avec mon appareil photo
et j'ai pris un certain nombre de photos
et nous y sommes allés c'était le soir
il faisait sombre donc à chaque fois que
je produis une photo mon flash se
déclenchait pour prendre l'objet que je
prenais en face c'est à dire les ruines
finalement de l'abbaye de Mortemer alors
que dans le cas où Muriel avait une
photo de ce type son flash ne se
déclenchait pas en fait on avait un peu
l'impression que l'appareil et la
technique de l'appareil avait détecté
que la luminosité
qu'il y avait en face était suffisante
pour prendre la photo alors qu'en fait
on était dans le loi complet
pratiquement
et donc nous sommes allés ensemble il y
avait plusieurs personnes on est
plusieurs appareils on s'est changé
qu'on a pris une photo en même temps à
l'endroit initial au début moi j'ai
obtenu la même photo et puis eux ils ont
tenu rien du tout et le flashait parti
alors on voit la clarté du flash mais on
voit bien qu'il y a pas de support là
on retrouve les fils barbelés qui sont
devant
alors vous allez voir que si on prend
cette petite partie là ici comme ceci on
a bien cette petite tête là avec les
yeux le nez on a vraiment l'impression
qu'il y a un animal sur son épaule une
chouette une chouette en l'occurrence
puisque c'est l'histoire veut que elle
avait effectivement une chouette avec
elle dans cet ami de morte mère
oui
vous en avez d'autres qui sont peut-être
encore plus étonnantes oui oui alors je
vais vous faire voir une photo là qui
est assez spectaculaire qui a été obtenu
il y a pas très très longtemps
alors voilà cette photo cette photo est
toute une histoire bien entendu
il s'agit d'un monsieur qui a pris cette
photo de ces deux enfants que l'on voit
ici et là
et il s'est aperçu que au développement
de la photo il a obtenu ceci et que il y
a une sorte de personnage supplémentaire
qui est apparu entre ces deux enfants
et ce personnage qui est un enfant aussi
bien sûr a été reconnu alors il s'agit
de
Daniel du prénom du petit garçon qui est
le garçon décédé de la sœur du monsieur
qui a pris cette photo et alors ce qui
est très touchant je dirais dans cette
image c'est que vous voyez ici il y a
comme une petite main là ici qui tient
une sorte de bouquet de fleurs vous
voyez qui se trouve devant sa bouche en
fait et c'est comme si il sentait ce
bouquet de fleurs pour pour le photo qui
existe réellement cette image n'existait
pas non non
c'est une image qui n'existait
l'image est tout à fait nouvelle
finalement c'est il y a pas de précédent
dans les photos de famille que ces
gens-là avaient
d'accord donc il y a pas de aujourd'hui
on est quand même face à une énigme on
est face à une énigme absolument
absolument mais qui vous conforte dans
l'idée que l'au-delà existe et qu'il y a
des manifestation de la absolument alors
ça n'est pas uniquement cet élément là
mais il est conforté par d'autres
éléments que l'on va peut-être enfin qui
sont
issus de la transcommunication
instrumentale ou d'autres manifestations
médiumniques qui viennent sans arrêt
renforcer cette idée que nous avons bien
à faire à un au-delà dans lequel il y a
des êtres qui vivent et pour nous ce
sont nos défunts
paranormale intervient sur la fin de nos
paroles et donc en fait sur les
vibrations restantes du dernier mot
qu'on a prononcé c'est très rapide d'où
l'intérêt justement là par exemple là ça
enregistre vous avez vous des exemples
concrets
ou vous espérez écouter
registre vous avez vous des exemples
concrets vous faire voir ici ce que ça
représente
je reprends je reprends le
[Musique]
je pense qu'il y aura quelque chose on
va vérifier oui alors donc ce qu'on va
faire on va essayer maintenant de
reprendre cette petite portion avec le
logiciel de traitement de son pour
[Musique]
ça doit être ça voilà on doit l'avoir en
principe dans cette partie là il s'en
peut faire ça
tu es très compétent a priori vous avez
entendu ça a priori j'ai entendu ça
alors à vérifier
[Musique]
c'est quand même bien
c'est
essayer de on va l'amplifier voir déjà
de retirer les bruits enfin une partie
des bruits tout au moins
c'est quand même enfin moi ça me
satisfait pas finalement parce que
c'est tangent c'est vraiment tangent
j'ai peur que si vous passez ça ça c'est
vraiment très très scandé et
moi à mon avis c'est sujet à cause de ça
s'ils sont convaincus du phénomène on ne
parle pas toujours avec les morts sur
commande ce n'est pas jackpot à tous les
jours
ils ne sont pas les seuls à travailler
dans ce domaine et bien d'autres
résultats auraient été obtenus
aujourd'hui vous n'êtes pas croyant
peut-être il ne reste pas moins que
certaines interrogations peuvent naître
en vos esprits lorsque vous entendez
parler des apparitions mariales alors
nous y reviendrons nous sommes avec le
Père François Brune nous parlons des
apparitions de la Vierge car les
premières apparitions remontent à très
très loin comme ça de tête vous souvenez
de la première apparition qui serait
noté dans l'histoire la première en
Occident serait au cinquième siècle sur
la petite colline où se trouve
actuellement à la cathédrale du Puy du
Puy-en-Velay
[Musique]
mais il y a également alors une sorte de
raz marée de fausses apparitions et
c'est un des gros problèmes comment
distinguer les vrais défausses c'est
incroyable le nom de gens qui ont
l'impression de recevoir des messages de
la Sainte Vierge alors
quand même les ouvrages d'où le premier
le Parlement nous parle à l'écoute de
l'au-delà enfin voilà série de
d'ouvrages où vous qui vous intéressez à
ces personnes qui tentent d'entrer en
contact avec l'au-delà il y aurait-il
quand même un timbre de voix qui ne
puisse pas appartenir à un imposteur et
qui soit figé sur une sur une bande
magnétique ça je ne pense pas bien sûr
dans un certain nombre de cas on peut
prouver que c'est une voie paranormale
parce qu'il manque les fondamentales
oui mais ça c'est vrai de quantité de
voix enregistrée venant de défunts ce
qui est vrai c'est que je ne pensais pas
qu'il y avait autant d'individus dans
des domaines aussi divers qui puissent
chercher matière à curiosité dans ce qui
pourrait être considéré comme il
recevable depuis le siècle des Lumières
l'essentiel c'est que l'on squat dans le
plaisir de la conversation
c'est de la philosophie aussi c'est
échappé au monde de la normalisation et
de se dire même si ce sont des
hallucinés ce qui est formidable c'est
qu'il soit aussi nombreux et qu'est-ce
qui peut faire qu'il soit porté par leur
âge lucination parce que une allégation
en tant que telle ça n'aurait rien
d'intéressant là toutes les personnes
qui viennent témoigner ce sont des gens
qui ont leur vie qui basculent dès lors
qu'il s'ouvrent à ce paranormal
et puis même si je suis dans l'au-delà
mais on nous garderons le contact
n'est-ce pas chiche que m'appeliez de
temps en temps pas mal ça serait pas mal
ça me ferait bien chanceler là enfin là
la boucle de boue
il réussirait de là-haut
ici alors
voilà et bien mon père
mais oui ça c'est bien passé une fois de
plus
c'est pas la première fois que vous
rencontrez visiblement oh non cela fait
au moins cette fille fois jusqu'à 10
aucune idée de fois bon c'est le leader
de l'émission
en plus mon père à bientôt merci à vous
et
reconnaître un intérêt pour ce qui de
phénomène et cornes la respectabilité
d'un individu alors c'est vrai que quand
il m'approche il me dit surtout ne dites
pas que nous sommes en relation etc
parce que ça serait préjudiciable à mes
fonctions au crédit qui me sont alloués
etc c'est évident
j'ai participé à quantité de congrès
dans différents pays alors j'ai dû
participer à plus de 25 engrais en
Italie j'en ai fait en Allemagne compris
à la télévision aussi au Luxembourg en
Belgique en Espagne au Portugal aux
États-Unis au Mexique à Porto Rico au
Brésil dans l'Argentine au Chili
alors là nous allons rencontrer mon ex
Simonet nous allons voir un peu les
résultats qu'elle a obtenu elle a
vraiment parmi les meilleures voix que
l'on ait reçu en France dans la soulagé
la souffrance de centaines de gens en
obtenant sur sa bande magnétique à la
voix de largeur disparue
[Musique]
toute ma vie j'ai même eu plus que 200
j'ai eu des visions j'ai vu tomber la
bonne Hiroshima je l'ai vu tomber de mon
lit j'étais jeune
je ne sais pas je ne sais plus de 100000
voix mais là celle que j'ai prennent moi
là c'est mon mari et la dernière de
Monique
alors je continue je courir là je leur
fais plusieurs fois
[Applaudissements]
bon je répète simplement la réponse
toute seule deux fois c'est moi c'est
moi c'est Monique
je suis heureuse dis-nous et tu es
heureuse
de ces funérailles le lendemain
au niveau de la voix ça chauffe pas
merci
quelque chose là moi j'ai l'impression
ça c'est une voix de femme quand même
j'ai l'impression
parce que on entendait bien elle avait
une voix claire
[Musique]
je ne peux pas le jurer mais je
reconnais la voix de mon mari dans
certains messages depuis Marshall aussi
puis des petites choses et puis des
petites choses
où la question que j'ai posée ou autre
chose moi je sens que celui de toute
façon je le champagne
ça va faire rire je l'ai bousculé
Olivier j'étais en train d'éplucher
d'éplucher des pommes et tout d'un coup
il y a eu un bruit j'étais accusé et un
bruit ici je me suis retournée
brutalement comme ça j'ai senti que je
bousculais quelqu'un et je vous jure
j'ai bousculé quelqu'un alors j'ai levé
la tête j'ai vu le silhouette de mon
mari près de moi je ne peux pas être
quelqu'un d'autre comme mon mari qui
serait permis de venir mais son nez
quand on en est quand j'ai plus chez mes
pommes
je suis sûr que je l'ai bousculé il y en
a qui dirait que je suis folle mais moi
j'en suis sûr tu es arrivé deux trois
fois
je comprends bien je suis pas mort la
Suisse je le comprends mal
on avait réalisé beaucoup de TCI avec
votre mari en plus de 1000 messages en
gros
c'est parce que j'en fais plus depuis
quelques mois sinon j'en aurai tous les
jours
plus les gens que je fais que j'aide
je vous dis en tout je suis un j'ai
dépassé les 100 000 j'en suis sûr
on va peu à peu avoir la preuve de ce
que la vie continue et de ce que
l'au-delà qui nous attend nous le
façonnons déjà sur terre
alors
le travail de Monique Simonet m'a
fournit des documents précieux que
j'utilise énormément dans les
conférences que je fais c'est une preuve
de plus parmi d'autres que j'en ai gardé
des quantités à travers le monde
et là je vais vous faire entendre
quelque chose donc
[Musique]
alors là c'est au Luxembourg là c'est
arrivé donc le 22 juin 87 on m'a
présente et puis peu à peu la voix de
l'au-delà va arriver
voilà ça commence à arriver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui est dit là c'est
l'éternité une parcelle d'éternité
âme principe esprit échappe à la
destruction le malheur vous ajoutez la
suite le malheur est aujourd'hui les
gens ont peur de la mort or la mort
n'est pas à craindre mais bien la
maladie et ce qui précède la mort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà alors cet enregistrement comment
vous l'avez obtenu et bien j'étais au
Luxembourg et c'était à travers le
haut-parleur d'un poste de radio on
l'entendait en direct en direct à
travers le haut-parleur mais en même
temps l'appareil était relié un système
d'enregistrement et donc on enregistrait
en même temps donc c'était pas quelque
chose qui vous ont fait écouter par la
suite non non non j'étais là au moment
même où c'est arrivé
voilà
[Musique]
alors dans l'église bien disons qu'il y
a actuellement
une évolution qui est en train de se
faire je reste assez mal vu en France
mais un peu moins qu'il y a quelques
années je n'ai jamais été mal vu en
Italie mais au Vatican ils sont
parfaitement au courant de ces
phénomènes là il les suivent il y a une
toute petite équipe de gens qui se sont
intéressés à ces phénomènes et qui
suivent le développement de ces
recherches retour à Toulouse
en fait le laboratoire de Yvelines on
n'a rien de officiel il a obtenu
quelques crédits il y a quelques années
de la part de son université mais cela
n'a pas duré
est-ce que j'organisais c'est quelque
chose de très simple
donc c'est une une version techniquement
améliorée d'une
expérience qui est réalisée depuis très
longtemps aux États-Unis donc on a un
paquet de cartes à jouer et donc on va
tirer une carte au hasard la laisser
d'autres tourner et ceux qui font
participer à l'expérience doivent
essayer de trouver laquelle ils vont
donc remplir des feuilles comme celle-ci
la première carte la deuxième carte etc
on va faire ça à 12 reprises et après
quoi moi le calcul statistique me
permettra de savoir s'ils ont répondu ou
non au hasard
et s'ils n'ont pas répondu au hasard
c'est l'éternel problème que pose ce
genre d'expérience dans la mesure où ils
n'ont pas vu la carte au sens ordinaire
s'il ne répondent pas au hasard s'il
tombe plus ou moins juste ce qu'ils
l'ont vu entre guillemets et ça
s'appelle vaincu une expérience de
voyage
la salle est libre vous pouvez vous
pouvez aller vous installer la 663 voilà
assis bien ça j'ai pas trouvé
de tout le monde a de quoi écrire
je vais aller chercher une boîte de
stylo
on en prêtera voilà celle dans la porte
est ouverte
[Musique]
on va attendre
alors il y a absolument tout il y a des
étudiants et des anciens étudiants à moi
il y a Yolande de Châtelet la voyante
avec qui nous expérimentons parce que ça
vous intéresse donc voilà le paquet de
12 cartes il y en a des Bleus au dos et
des rouges mais c'est pour tremper
l'adversaire donc Jocelyn bat le paquet
le coupe et tu écartes une carte
comme tu veux tu as des cartouches que
tu places devant Laetitia
donc il en couple
voilà maintenant vous avez une minute
pour inscrire la première carte sur la
feuille
on peut la retourner
la dame de coeur
est venu me voir la première fois elle
m'a raconté bon une histoire des défaits
qu'elle avait vécu et
je lui ai dit ben écoutez je vous crois
je n'ai pas de raison de penser que vous
êtes une affabulatrice vous me racontez
cette histoire mais moi il me faut autre
chose il me faut ces tests à base de jeu
de cartes et elle les a réussi et
j'étais en train de prier quand j'ai eu
vraiment tous ces flashs qui me sont
arrivés à ce moment là j'ai appelé le
monsieur l'Union parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'il y a des événements que je ressens
des choses importantes j'appelle
monsieur Lignon et je lui dis voilà ce
qui se passe je vois beaucoup de morts
je vois assez et surtout surtout je vois
une petite fille qui se noie et tout le
monde la regarde
et j'étais vraiment il paraît dans un
état d'après monsieur Lignon j'étais
vraiment mal et le mercredi le mercredi
à la télévision on annonçait ce
tremblement de terre en Colombie et en
effet envoyé cette petite fille dans la
boue qui malheureusement ça m'est resté
gravé et en effet tout le monde doit
regarder parce que ça a été sur la terre
entière tout le monde l'a vu ces petites
filles qui se noyait qu'on n'a pas pu
sauver la première fois je les ai
recommencé trois fois de suite elle est
calcule j'étais tellement impressionnée
c'est pas possible tu es là quelques
chiffres sur une feuille de papier et
c'est quelques chiffres sont en train de
te dire que la voyance c'est une réalité
ça y est on remplit la 11e ligne bon
donc je récupère les feuilles de tout le
monde
les vierges
pas les laisser traîner passer comme
c'est plus ou moins une fois d'esprit
on peut dire que la ressemblance entre
ces réponses et les réponses exactes et
dans l'ensemble beaucoup trop forte pour
qu'on retienne l'explication par le
hasard
pourquoi des universités en Angleterre
ou en Allemagne continue-t-elle leur
recherche dans la parade psychologique
et pas nous
peu importe
Yvelines en persiste tout seul dans ses
études
[Musique]
voilà
c'est ici
[Musique]
c'est un médium et je le connais depuis
des années c'est quelqu'un qui j'ai
toute confiance d'abord parce qu'il est
honnête et c'est la première des
qualités il faut exiger d'un média
comment vous l'avez connu maintenant ce
médium mon père est dans une salle
justement où il y a des millions qui
interviennent au public 40 ou 50
personnes qui ont déposé des photos de
défunts
sur la table
et
il nous raconter un petit peu lui-même
comment ça se passe ils se sent
quelquefois tirés à prendre telle photo
plutôt que de l'autre
comme ça
moi j'ai pas eu d'expérience mais
j'aimerais bien avoir une par rapport à
ma maman qui est partie et j'aimerais
bien qu'elles viennent donc je sais pas
on verra bien dans l'avenir et parler de
Monsieur Roussel vous vous espérez
quelque chose aujourd'hui oui
j'espère qu'il va me faire passer un
message vous avez apporté une photo vous
pouvez nous la montrer oui bien sûr
c'est parti le jour de l'Ascension
qui sont partis de l'autre côté et j'ai
eu au quotidien comme ça voilà par
exemple je fais une référence à un film
qui est un film de science-fiction
pourtant qui s'appelle le 6e sens ça
vous parle je l'ai pas vu
ce qui me parle ces gosses parce que
gosse on se demande toujours comment ça
se ça fonctionne la mort et ben dans
gosse on le voit qui sort de son corps
et on voit une un rayon de lumière qui
écorce spirituel et ça ça fonctionne
comme ça voilà il faut qu'elle vienne me
faire un message pour qu'elle vienne
mener leur exact preuve je veux une
preuve
on va passer l'expérience de médiumnité
j'ai bien insisté que ce n'est pas de la
voyance il ne se passe rien il y a rien
à voir il y a jusqu'à écouter voilà ce
n'est pas moi qui vais décider ce sont
les personnes qui sont devenus
invisibles qui vont venir vous donner
des messages voilà
d'une jeune fille en survêtement rouge
c'est votre fille
il y en a deux de l'autre côté
parce qu'ils sont ensemble
ils sont partis la même année ou avec
quelques la même année ils sont tous les
deux ensemble comme ça vous leur parlez
tous les jours parce que alors c'est
votre jeune fille qui me dit qu'est-ce
que tu es barbare qu'est-ce que ça me
fait plaisir mais je ne peux pas
répondre à toutes tes interrogations ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que je suis
bien et que je ne sais pas quand elle
est partie si elle faisait des études ou
de la recherche mais de l'autre côté de
la recherche scientifique ou de la
recherche
d'accord parce qu'elle me dit de l'autre
côté je suis dans des bibliothèques donc
on appelle ça des Annales Akashiques en
mots très compliqué mais elle est dans
des bibliothèques de la recherche
spirituelle sur le sacré elle me donne
d'accord voilà
il y a combien de temps qu'il est parti
un an
25 octobre cette année
la lettre J correspond à qui son prénom
c'est son prénom c'est Jean Jean-Pierre
Jacques
il demande des prières il a besoin de
s'élever voilà vous êtes allé le voir à
l'hôpital et oui parce qu'il me dit je
te remercie de ton accompagnement parce
que quand tu me caressais les mains ça
me faisait énormément de bien voilà et
qui est Chantal
[Musique]
et il l'embrasse de là-haut d'accord
voilà j'ai un monsieur qui s'appelle
Albert qui est décédé il est je pense
qu'il était égyptologue ou qu'il a parlé
de l'Égypte ou qu'il a écrit sur
l'Egypte il peut voir les tas de
bouquins ça marque pour qui ça oui
l'Égypte ça marque sur ce monsieur
il a écrit des livres il a fait des
écrits
il était élégant ce monsieur je l'ai en
costume comment on dit prince de Galles
il était toujours en prince de Galles ou
pas ou c'est simplement aujourd'hui qui
se met comme ça 80%
des ingrédients bleu ciel c'est ce qui
monte il est à côté de vous voilà il y a
quelqu'un qui s'est pendu autour de vous
il y a quelques années
il y a 7 ou 8 ans je pense non
pas entendu parler alors c'est pas pour
vous c'est dans le fond là-bas et c'est
pas pour vous à côté madame la dame qui
est à côté de la dame
Isabelle bousculer votre voisine la
claque voilà oui non j'ai effectivement
un oncle qui s'est pendu il y a quatre
ans il est arrivé en même temps il est à
côté de vous il est sur le champ en même
temps c'était un autre que vous
connaissiez bien
le paradis l'enferme et tout ça pour moi
j'ai rien vu de tout ça et dimanche on
ne pouvait plus je suis parti et j'ai
fait mon bonhomme de chemin j'avais
accompli ma vie voilà donc j'ai pas
souffert voilà moi je vois un défunt je
donne pas le message pour la personne il
va me suivre derrière moi pourquoi tu
l'as pas donné donc ça suit pendant une
heure à peu près donc il va prendre le
métro il va me suivre avec le métro ou
quelquefois ils arrivent avant les gens
dire à 14h30 ils vont déjà être là en me
disant moi je veux passer le premier moi
je veux passer le premier donc on
faisait des photos ici ils ont pas sur
la table je fais comme j'ai fait en
direct je dis au fond là-bas il y a
quelqu'un donc ils suivent ils sont
comme vous et moi dans leur corps
spirituel et ils vivent
la dame qui a tu es en bordeaux oui je
vais quand même venir sur vous parce que
j'ai votre papa qui est là
il arrive vous l'avez bien connu ou pas
mal connue mais à la fin de sa vie vous
l'avez connu
euh c'est un fin de vie a été terrible
non mais c'est moi qui vais vous le dire
ça mais est-ce que vous l'avez est-ce
que vous l'avez vu physiquement oui
parce qu'il arrive doucement comme ça il
y a des difficultés à marcher
comme ça et il dit je suis parti
douloureusement mais il me dit une fois
que je suis passé de l'autre côté ça a
été quand même et il vient pour vous
aujourd'hui pour vous demander pardon
voilà pour le pardon et vous faut lui
faut essayer de pardonner c'est ce que
vous voulez il vient comme ça d'accord
voilà c'est des un monsieur vous avez
posé sur la table c'est qui c'est votre
ça me suffit que je me suis occupé
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie d'accord alors
il va passer et c'est douloureux ce
qu'il me dit il va passer ce monsieur je
me suis le monsieur que vous êtes occupé
jusqu'à la fin de il va très bien donc
il va certainement venir pour vous
remercier mais c'est ce monsieur qui a
envoyé votre papa
ce qui se met entre vous deux je suis
obligé de vous le dire c'est sinon après
quand je rentre chez moi il me suit dans
la rue il me disait pourquoi tu lui as
pas dit parce que après cette douleur
que vous subissez là après vous allez
voir il y a une paix intérieure qui va
tomber d'accord voilà vous avez une
question
c'était surtout pour ça et je voudrais
savoir si vous avez eu mon père si
justement il a retrouvé ma mère aussi
vous êtes prêt à gérer la réponse
il me dit on s'est croisé et il fait
quel gâchis
à combien de temps il y a pas longtemps
pour moi
ah oui c'est tout récent
vous lui avez dit cet après-midi je vais
faire une séance est-ce que tu peux te
manifester parce qu'elle me dit je t'ai
entendu je suis au rendez-vous voilà
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de
la séquence d'aujourd'hui mon père était
excellente
comment on appréhende le fait que ça
s'est bien passé que les détails étaient
vraiment probants
les réactions des gens qui reçoivent les
messages de l'au-delà il y a aucun doute
je peux pas les considérer comme des
illumines et c'est pas possible
c'était tellement important alors madame
ça c'était vraiment la preuve la preuve
je suis venue aujourd'hui en demandant à
ma maman de venir pour me laisser le
message qu'il existe bien autre chose et
donc j'ai ma preuve aujourd'hui je l'ai
quel que soit le nom que l'on met
derrière ces messages des fins des
pouvoirs télépathiques une chose est
sûre c'est que le CNRS ne l'étudie
toujours pas
ce qui paraît encore le plus recevable
par notre société et sans aucun doute le
pouvoir de nos vieux guérisseurs
[Musique]
ce dont c'est le magnétisme le pouvoir
de soulager les gens également la
radiesthésie sentir les choses sentir
les choses qu'on dit on connaît bien les
sourciers savoir où creuser un puits
vous voyez sentir ou passe l'eau ou il y
a un problème dans une maison pourquoi
on se sent mal à telle et tel endroit
etc c'est une sensibilité que l'on a à
détecter les choses à sentir les choses
ce qui se passe
[Musique]
je reviens par là
vous pouvez m'expliquer ce qui se passe
dans votre maison
on pense qu'il y a un phénomène et qui
fait qu'on n'est pas bien dans la maison
donc on a demandé à Jean-Marc de venir
voir quelle était ce phénomène et je
peux m'asseoir sur le canapé vous sentez
oppressé ici
comment
vous pouvez pas vous asseoir là c'est
vrai que ça commence à m'empresser ça on
fait ça ici non
vous n'aimez pas
usé
c'est tout
il y a de l'eau il y a de l'eau sur
cette partie de la maison il y a une
nappe de sous qui met des ondes
négatives c'est vrai que ce sont pas
bien dans ces cas-là pourquoi de l'Aube
émettrai les ondes négatives
j'ai pas la réponse
et on constate on constate et dans ces
cas-là va aussi c'est de l'eau qui
stagne il y a pas grand chose à faire
sinon de creuser venez voir et vous
asseoir
si vous mettre dans les mêmes conditions
parce que moi je ressens d'accord
et cette sensation d'oppression claque
j'arrête
qu'est-ce que ça donne
[Musique]
tranquillement
quand on appuie ça fait mal ici
vous allez me dire si votre bras sont
gourdis
la chaleur s'amplifie je vous touche pas
et là le bras continue à s'engourdir
quelque chose vous pouvez prendre une
bouteille vous pouvez prendre un
tour
si vous levez votre bras vous faites des
mouvements avec votre poignet ou tourne
en poignet ça donne quoi
il reste une inflammation d'accord mais
là par contre vous pouvez faire ce que
vous voulez avec votre vous pouvez le
serrer avec le bout des doigts comme
on va demander à Charles d'aller
chercher du pain tu viens me chercher un
petit morceau de pain
soulever le fauteuil je pense ça va y
aller voilà très bien
ce matin j'arrive pas à couper le pain
et pour le gamin j'ai coupé le pain
comme ça
une source qui passe par ici rien qu'en
passant dessus
voilà
quand je passerai quand je vais passer
au-dessus de la source
voilà tout comme les bacs faisaient
avec leurs baguettes c'est exactement la
même chose
de construire aujourd'hui on fait plus
attention
on ne fait absolument plus attention à
ça et on peut se retrouver avec bon ce
mal-être puisque dans cette coin de la
pièce où il reste pas
c'est ce qui m'interpelle le plus à
travers travers ces phénomènes ce point
d'interrogation ou aujourd'hui la
science but si ce n'est que de dire ma
foi sont des pour être très poli ce sont
des âneries ou des bêtises je pense que
le problème scientifique si aujourd'hui
il dit
Max est faux qui n'explique qu'il
explique d'une manière rationnelle
pourquoi c'est faux qu'ils expliquent
pourquoi ça n'existe pas et pourquoi
beaucoup de gens encore aujourd'hui vont
consulter des magnétiseurs ou des radiés
radiesthésiste pour tel ou tel problème
si ça n'existait pas on en parlerait
plus depuis très longtemps
sur internet je me suis étonné de
l'absence de recherche scientifique
officielle en la matière en revanche les
associations poussent comme des
champignons comme si les gens osaient
enfin en parler
comme ça ça sera parfait
[Applaudissements]
alors
[Musique]
je me suis dit je ne suis pas tout seul
à me poser la question je suis pas tout
seul à rien il comprend je suis pas tout
seul en avoir eu peur
et bon il faut bien que quelqu'un qui se
jette à l'eau pour pour dire bah
maintenant on peut en parler en toute
sérénité en toute tranquillité et sans
avoir peur du préjugé et du ridicule et
du ridicule évidemment
[Musique]
c'est traité à des examens dans
laboratoire en présence huissier et
aussi d'illusioniste professionnel qui
ne conteste pas l'identité des
phénomènes
à tous merci je sais cette fois la
parole à nos cavité que je demande au
pays comme il se doit c'est Jean-Pierre
Girard
[Applaudissements]
je suis très heureux d'être
ici parmi nos amis sixième sens nous
avons un contact assez récent finalement
avec Jean-François qui préside au
destinée de sixième sens avec ses amis
associés je suis pas pro par un normal
je suis pas antiparanormal c'est-à-dire
que je souhaite avant tout qu'on puisse
discuter faire de l'information de la
recherche sur ces domaines-là mais pas
isolé pas seul moi je voudrais qu'on me
donne une réponse sur ces phénomènes que
je produis je voudrais y répondre et
j'ai tapé la porte quoi pas des
laboratoires de parapsychologie exotique
entre guillemets non non je me suis
adressé à des scientifiques pur et dur
lorsque le pouvoir qu'il a
je l'aide est-elle Jean long qu'on peut
effectivement l'acquérir c'est comme
dans tout domaine pour toute personne
qui s'intéresse au sujet si on se
retrouve isolé premièrement elle vit en
Vasco donc elle peut pas avancer elle
peut pas progresser elle ne peut pas
évoluer c'est un sujet qui est très
difficile à aborder il fait peur au
premier abord donc il y a que dans ce
type d'associations où on peut
rencontrer des gens qui sont assez
ouverts pour
comme les nôtres on a souvent des des
choses où les gens aussi ou alors ça ça
réconforte on dit on n'est pas
complètement
seul et peut-être plus rassuré de dire
on sait pas dans notre tête on n'est pas
on est normaux quoi parce qu'il y a des
moments se poser des questions quand
même
voilà Jean-Pierre bienvenue chez moi
de découvrir un petit peu le haut dans
lequel tu vis alors le cœur de
l'association c'est la le coeur de
l'association c'est là ce qui m'a
amené à m'intéresser un peu au
paranormal c'est c'est la voyance
j'avais une amie qui tirait les cartes
et qui m'assurait que les cartes
pouvaient lui parler
[Musique]
responsable d'une association d'études
et recherche impérative je suis amené à
constater certains cas d'abus
d'escroquerie ou de charlatanisme dans
le domaine de la de la voyance notamment
je voudrais qu'elle je voudrais savoir
quelle conduite à tenir les services de
l'État nous conseille de suivre sachant
que notre association contrairement au
charlatan n'a pas de budget permettant
en justice pour lutter contre ces
mauvaises pratiques de façon synthétique
je lui demande un de faire avancer les
recherches en parachychologie en
autorisant officiellement les recherches
et les études dans le domaine de lutter
efficacement contre les charlatanisme et
les abus en tout genre le ménage on
constate dans ce domaine faire le ménage
pour laisser une place nette ou
scientifique qui comme Jean-Pierre
Girard
s'interroge sur la parade psychologie et
même des investigations très très très
honnête très poussé
le ménage peut être fait facilement sans
que tu aies un franc déboursé
tu vas voir tu vas au RG tu signales à
la préfecture c'est tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
moi je suis né comme ça je suis né je
n'ai passionné par ces phénomènes enfin
aussi aussi loin que remonte ma mémoire
c'était peut-être des émissions de radio
à l'époque il y avait un appel
jean-nocher je me rappelle j'étais gosse
dehors 5 ou 6 ans qui racontait des
histoires extraordinaires sur les
extraterrestres et tout ça ça m'avait ça
m'avait passionné je crois que c'est ça
en fait qui m'a déclenché l'intérêt que
j'ai pu avoir pour pour le sujet et
après je me suis toujours dit mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là faut que j'aille
à l'école c'est pas marrant faut que je
subisse mes parents c'est pas marrant
faut obéir c'est pas marrant mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là en fin de compte
ça m'a toujours tarabuster mais
qu'est-ce qu'on est venu faire sur cette
galère
donc au départ on avait une revue qui
s'appelle paration qu'on a créé en 1989
mais au niveau diffusion de
l'information il y avait pour le grand
public il y avait que des revues qui
vous vendent du bonheur pas cher à
partir de la signe astrologique des
planètes ce jour-là je me suis dit il
faut essayer de faire quelque chose d'un
peu plus sérieux parce que il y a rien
de sérieux sur le sujet souvent c'est
des revues
astrologie mais une tenue pas terrible
donc j'ai voulu essayer de faire quelque
chose qui qui soit à la frontière de la
science pour essayer de comprendre ce
que ce qui était tous ces phénomènes
donc j'ai créé par la science comme ça
d'ailleurs la phrase centrale c'est
cette revue est faite pour les gens qui
cherchent et non pour ceux qui pensent à
la retrouver bon donc c'est vrai que ça
élimine tout de suite tous ceux qui sont
persuadés de tenir la vérité de savoir
que quand ils sont morts ils vont là il
sera un quart de ceci cela j'en sais
rien moi
[Musique]
donc là j'ai des photos assez étranges
qui présentent des phénomènes bizarres
qui se passe au col de Vence et je vais
préparer un livre sur le sujet
à chaque fois qu'ils vont là-bas lui et
toute son équipe
il y a des souhaits de distorsion soit
des objets qui apparaissent mais qui
qu'on ne voit pas et qui apparaissent
quand on quand on prend les photos il
est pas spécialiste parce que j'ai vu la
première fois les photos du col de Vence
je n'y ai pas cru une seconde avec un
petit logiciel ou un appareil trafiqué
n'importe qui est capable d'obtenir de
tels rendus mais Jean-Michel me
certifiant que l'on pouvait voir les
résultats en direct grâce aux appareils
photos numériques me décide d'aller voir
par moi-même j'ai aussi un appareil
photo numérique et je suis certain de
son bon fonctionnement
[Musique]
quand on me propose un bouquin ou un
reportage sur un sujet bien précis
j'aime bien voir par moi-même si
effectivement il y a quelque chose si
j'ai à faire à des farfelus ou à des
illuminés
[Musique]
on est en train de monter au col de
Vence pour voir
les étranges phénomènes qui s'y
manifestent notamment quand monsieur Bic
et présent donc moi ma grande question
c'est les phénomènes qui se manifestent
là-bas
ce qui est Monsieur Bic monsieur Bic
est-il lié au phénomène c'est vrai que
beaucoup ça se passe souvent quand je
suis là ça c'est vrai mais toute
personne je pense toute personne qui va
s'associer à un morceau de terrain ou un
lieu va s'emprunner il va se passer des
trucs au bout d'un moment
tu vas dans un endroit tu te poses des
questions quand le phénomène va
commencer c'est là où s'excitant tu vas
créer une relation avec lui donc ici on
rentre dans une zone d'anomalie
permanente
de manière toujours
qui que ça se passe
[Musique]
bon alors on prend des photos on
explique on est des on aime bien les
papillons de nuit donc on croit que les
photos pour moi il y a rien c'est juste
des appareils numériques on se fait
plaisir de prendre des petites photos
comme ça autour de nous jusqu'à tant
qu'on arrive à avoir des anomalies tout
ce qui est un petit
[Musique]
peu
bizarre son nom
[Musique]
peut-être ah bah oui c'est la plaque de
la voiture
je ne suis pas doué pour le paranormal
pour l'instant je suis déçu moi j'ai
rien moi j'ai rien
ça c'est une photo pas normale mais
c'est pas une photo paranormal
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est
une lumière à vos pieds
[Musique]
avec un faisceau alors regarde je dois
grandis ça c'était quand ils étaient
debout là où c'était debout là tu as vu
tu as une lumière tellement forte
qu'elle diffuse tu as vu des faisceaux
de haut en bas
il y avait rien à faire ça c'est VOUS
AUSSI regarde sur la photo vous êtes là
regarde
[Musique]
une source de lumière tellement forte
qu'elle fait en plus un rayon de lumière
à vos pires rien à vos pires parce que
des baskets lumineuses
alors qu'il y en avait pas regarde la
puissance du feu
je sais pas je peux pas te dire ce que
c'est cette énergie quoi cette lumière
est-ce que c'est un objet est-ce que
c'est autre chose que ce que c'est un
fantôme c'est ça qu'on appelle un
fantôme je sais pas
est-ce que c'est un spectre je sais pas
c'est c'est ce qui est fou c'est qu'on
ne voit pas l'ONU c'est très important
de dire que quand on prend la photo on a
rien vu on a aucun mérite de faire ses
photos
ah oui tu voulais comment ça marche ce
truc là
et là tu appuies là dessus
[Musique]
quand tu prends des photos toi aussi
la lumière parce que des fois
ça veut dire tout à l'heure j'ai pris la
photo quand j'ai pris la photo tout à
l'heure
on va voir si ça
une interférence numérique puisque
auparavant pierre prenait les mêmes
photos avec un appareil traditionnel
c'est en tout cas aujourd'hui
incompréhensible pour mes chers neurones
et le sommeil va être très difficile à
trouver
est-ce que tu
[Musique]
tu creux départ que que Pierre big était
farfelu parce que la façon dont il
présentait les choses me paraissait un
peu légère aussi léger au niveau de du
contenu c'est-à-dire faire un bouquin
sur des photos ça me paraissait pas
évident alors que il y a une telle
quantité de photos une telle variété de
photos et une telle multiplicité de
témoignages et d'image que là j'ai
vraiment matière à travailler j'ai quand
même voulu venir voir sur place ce que
ça donne
lui le relie au phénomène ovni moi je
suis pas du tout convaincu que ce soit
un phénomène OVNI qui se passe ici pour
moi c'est plutôt un problème projection
d'énergie un problème de projection ou
de liens entre des personnes liées à ce
lieu ce lieu qui est lui-même lié à
autre chose il y a peut-être un sas un
passage avec notre univers j'ai pas
d'explication j'ai des hypothèses
je suis monté ici parce que je
recherchais un coin pour la nature pour
la veiller et on était là on faisait une
vieille comme d'habitude et le 5 mars
1994 à 23 heures
c'est l'étoilée pas devant super décor
il me sort un engin triangulaire
triangle
et donc en étant un spectacle
hallucinant parce que c'était quelque
chose de gigantesque majestueux pas de
bruit et cette signée au-dessus de nous
c'était sa durée 2 minutes 30
l'observation et on était marqué à vie
quoi à partir de ce jour-là et
aujourd'hui et ben voilà donc c'est le
mystère des photos on a des photos de
toutes sortes des lumières qui fait des
boules lumineuses et des flashs des
objets qui devraient pas y être et qui
qui s'y trouvent ils manipulation
du temps les manipulations matérielles
enfin tout ce qui est autour de toi a
fait de la matière et pour toi c'est
quoi c'est des messages de d'entité de
d'extraterrestres
c'est c'est très difficile à expliquer
ça c'est c'est hallucinant dans le sens
que tu as l'impression que c'est truqué
ils font ce qu'ils veulent avec la photo
ils retirent un objet en rajoute un
autre donc c'est sûr que aussi je serais
un peu déçu si demain on nous apprend de
la réponse
voilà ce que vous avez là c'est ça bon
on passera autre chose
parce que c'est toujours le fantasme tu
sais le rêve faut pas tant que tu sais
pas ça permet toujours d'avoir cette
envie de charger le jour sont apportées
on va passer à autre chose alors tu es
content
[Musique]
à force d'y réfléchir je suis arrivé à
penser que c'était peut-être un des plus
grandes défis que la nature et jetée à
l'intelligence humaine parce que bien
entendu c'est phénomènes sont naturels
ils ont leur origine dans la
personnalité des individus
et nous avons nous des pouvoirs inconnus
et l'étude de ces pouvoirs inconnus
vraiment oui c'est un défi énorme qui
est jeté à la rationalité
les enjeux paraissent donc énormes
nouvelle religion Nouvelair scientifique
nouveau moyen de communication
comme les Grecs avec le tonnerre le
Noron probablement pas de réponse de
notre vivant
[Musique]